Let me give you some data about Poland
and Polish democracy.
The lowest unemployment in European Union is Poland.
The highest GDP after COVID in European Union is Poland.
One of the lowest debts in European Union is Poland.
So don't give us this rubbish
about the need of educated immigration
as we heard yesterday.
We don't need your doctors,
we don't need your engineers.
Take them. Take them all and pay for them.
We don't need them.
You know why?
Because there's a zero terrorist attacks in Poland.
Why? Because.
Because there's no illegal migration in Poland.
So don't give me this look,
don't give me this arguments about the populism,
because this is a fact.
This is your data from euro start.
So we don't need your engineers,
we don't need your doctors.
Take them. Do not.
Do not teach us about democracy,
because we know what the democracy is.
So learn from Poland.
Be like Poland.